con toda la economía por supuesto de la
mano de daniela blandon dani bienvenida
nuevamente vamos a hablar de eeuu donde
se disparó la inflación en ese país ya
se conoció este dato claro que sin
noticias frescas que le traemos en raúl
porque fue el 8,5 por ciento interanual
la inflación en marzo de 2022 en eeuu
este es el mayor nivel desde diciembre
de
1981 y lo que evidencia es que los
precios están subiendo con más fuerza
porque en febrero lanzadera del 79 por
ciento el impulso lo dieron por supuesto
los precios de los combustibles y por
eso se espera que en las próximas horas
la casa blanca anuncie medidas al
respecto por ejemplo la autorización el
próximo verano del uso del combustible
es 5 este es un combustible que tiene un
15 por ciento de etanol y el resto de
gasolina y que está prohibido durante
esta época del año para evitar la
contaminación atmosférica porque
normalmente se usa una mezcla del 10 por
ciento bueno dani y continuamos con otra
noticia sin blanca se declaró en default
el gobierno de este país es de poco más
de 20 millones de habitantes anunció que
dejará de pagar temporalmente de su
deuda externa en medio de una grave
crisis de liquidez y a la espera también
de un rescate del fondo monetario
internacional
la ira pública crece instr y la ncaa
persiste en los apagones y la escasez de
alimentos el martes miles salieron a las
calles en colombo exigiendo la renuncia
del primer ministro
estamos todos aquí porque nos está
afectando la economía de gran cambio un
día antes el primer ministro pidió
paciencia y culpó a la pandemia de
coronavirus la que calificó como la peor
crisis económica del país en décadas la
pandemia perjudicó las remesas y diezmó
la industria turística que representa
una décima parte de la producción
económica del país
bastante aunque garantizamos la
seguridad de la vida de las personas en
la pandemia no pudimos evitar caer en
este abismo económico
los analistas dicen que la mala gestión
del gobierno años de recortes de
impuestos desacertados y préstamos de
alto interés con china han empeorado la
crisis además la prohibición de los
fertilizantes químicos condujo a una
reducción de los rendimientos de las
cosechas lo que perjudicó una de las
principales exportaciones del país el té
de ceilán
ahora el gobierno ha anunciado que
suspenderá temporalmente los pagos de su
deuda externa para concentrarse en pagar
el combustible y otros bienes esenciales
con los dólares que le quedan
y no sólo es la ncaa danny porque rusia
también está en aprietos para el pago de
su deuda claro y la historia es la
siguiente la semana pasada ese país
tenía que pagar alrededor de 650
millones de dólares en obligaciones de
deuda externa pero hizo arreglos para
intentar pagar en rublos y no en dólares
como dice el contrato original esto
después de que eeuu le congelará sus
cuentas para la agencia de calificación
standard and poor's una de las más
grandes del mundo esto equivale a un
'default selectivo' quiere decir que un
país deja de pagar una de sus
obligaciones aunque no todas pero el
kremlin opina lo contrario dice que
tiene fondos suficientes y amenazó con
llevar el asunto a instancias judiciales
para defenderse escuchamos
está claro que no hay razones objetivas
para tal incumplimiento rusia tiene todo
lo que necesita para cumplir con todas
sus obligaciones pero por otro lado la
posición poco constructiva de nuestros
oponentes puede complicar la situación y
ante todo lo que está ocurriendo esta
guerra y las sanciones europa sigue en
su búsqueda de fuentes alternativas de
hidrocarburos cariocas y letonia por
ejemplo dejará de importar gas ruso
desde el primero de enero y construirá
una terminal de gas licuado para 2023 o
2024 alemania está acelerando la
construcción de proyectos de energía con
fuentes renovables y grecia dijo que su
país acelerará la exploración gasífera
para ayudar a reemplazar el gas ruso
que
todos en europa y en grecia nos damos
cuenta de que estamos experimentando el
final de una era y el comienzo de una
nueva ahora estamos comprendiendo de la
manera más dura la importancia de la
autonomía energética la seguridad
energética y los pasos aún más rápidos
que debemos tomar tanto a nivel nacional
como europeo en un mundo que cambia
rápidamente y se vuelve cada vez más
y finalizamos este segundo bloque
económico de directo américa con los
indicadores dan y bueno las bolsas del
mundo caen a mínimos de un mes europa
opera mixto con leves variaciones aunque
se están esperando por supuesto mayores
reacciones hacia la hora del cierre por
la inflación en eeuu de hecho el mercado
se está preparando para una apertura al
alza en wall street' dar y gracias por
toda la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más para pasar ahora a los
deportes